at first glance the halo franchise seems
like the standard super soldier kills
aliens saves the universe and then
choose bubble gum narrative that we've
seen a billion times before what's
really the difference between doom guy
and master chief besides the fact that
carl urban played one of them in that
movie that one time that we all try to
forget about though to be fair i am here
for carl urban to play master chief
actually very here for it but despite
the seemingly straightforward story told
across its six mainline titles the halo
universe has one of the richest and
densest mythos in all of gaming all
delivered through numerous spin-off
games novels movies short films graphic
novels hell even an audio drama it's
actually a really good one too mark
hamill's in it so with halo infinite
promising to build on all of this lore
it can easily feel overwhelming to
newcomers don't worry we've got you like
master chief has cortana
except for except for at the end there
regardless we're going to take you on
the great journey through the complete
timeline of the halo franchise
[Music]
while the halo game started with halo
combat evolved the story of the halo
universe begins much earlier starting in
15 million bce
this is going to be a [ __ ] long
timeline video some 15 million years ago
give a take a couple thousand hero there
an ancient race known as the precursors
seeded the galaxy with life creating
species such as humans and the
forerunners they hoped that one day one
of the races would carry the mantle of
responsibility their belief that they
quote most developed species would
become benevolent stewards of life in
the galaxy protecting biodiversity and
not getting involved in conflicts
between different species unless it was
necessary think kind of like the
federation and the prime directive from
star trek though with a bit more smug
superiority eventually 5 million years
later the precursors chose humanity to
carry the mantle because you know we're
cool like that making the forerunners
jealous the forerunners went full cylon
and rebelled against their creators
forcing the precursors to flee the milky
way galaxy and retreat to the large mag
meglianic meglianic
magellanic ah yeah no that makes much
more sense the g is yeah
to the large magellanic cloud a small
dwarf galaxy orbiting our own with
little to survive on most of the
remaining precursors turn themselves
into dust for later rehydration kind of
like that scene in the atomos batman
movie
[Applause]
afterwards the forerunners took up the
mantle twisting the ideology to mean
that they had a duty to keep quote
lesser races underneath them so less
federation more nazi after that humanity
and the forerunners lived mostly on
separate sides of the galaxy until one
day a hundred thousand years ago
humanity out of nowhere began destroying
forerunner worlds angered the
forerunners and humanity began a
thousand year war with the sexy sanchion
allying themselves with humanity however
humanity wasn't destroying forerunner
planets as an act of aggression but
because they were being pushed out of
their space by the flood a parasitic
life-form that consumed everything it
touched and turned it into more flood
the forerunners who had yet to encounter
the flood however believed that the
parasite was a lie told by humanity to
justify their aggression during the war
humanity found the last living precursor
called the primordial who revealed the
horrifying origins of the flood a secret
so dark that the humans who heard it
killed themselves immediately upon
learning it
so um
warning i guess cause i'm gonna tell you
right now after the precursors turned
themselves into dust their dust became
corrupted instead the dust mutated them
into horrifying flood creatures under
the control of the singular grave mind
think the board queen but less sexy or
more sexy you know what i'm not here to
kink shame you like what you like the
gravemind soon decided to get revenge on
all life in the galaxy by removing free
will and turning everything into the
flood
humanity continued to wage war against
both forerunners and flood nearly
beating both forcing the flood to
retreat at least presumably but
eventually losing to the forerunners as
punishment the forerunners devolved
humanity to hunter-gatherers and exiled
them to some random little planet called
uh earth meanwhile the san tsiyun were
quarantined to their homeworld for
allying with humanity forbidden to ever
leave yet while they had won the war the
forerunner military was exhausted and a
game of thronesian political schism
began to brew in their government
cementing the tragedy to come sadly not
as much of a tragedy as game of thrones
final season i'll take a galactic
genocide over bran on the throne any day
with humanity gone the flood began
infecting foreigner worlds making the
foreigners understand the threat too
little too late
realizing that they couldn't win against
the flood two political factions formed
one formed behind the died act who
wished to create shield worlds planets
completely encased in metal to protect
them from the flood while the master
builder wished to create the halo arrays
giant rings that would destroy all life
in the galaxy thereby starving the flood
with an ark being created to reseed the
galaxy afterwards now i've got to be
honest here the didact in most of halo
fiction is framed as the evil one here
because um
i guess because he has a british accent
but galactic genocide is
also not a great option
the halo arrays were eventually chosen
so the died act rebelled and began to
use a technology called the composer
which turned forerunner and human
warriors into a.i prometheans again this
is very borg-like and there's a lot of
parallels between star trek and halo
which is probably why i like this series
to be honest
however the diet act was eventually
defeated and imprisoned on a shield
world called requiem and forced into
stasis basically he was just taking a
centuries long nap nap the forerunners
began working to build the halo arrays
and the dynax wife the librarian began
collecting dna samples of every species
in order to reseed the galaxy with later
on the forerunners even tested the halos
on the shanxian homeworld killing those
sad little guys dead but at this point a
lot of them were hedonists because they
had been quarantined for so long so
most of them probably died having sex
which
not a bad way to go
focused on the halo arrays the
forerunners built an ai called mendicant
bias to fight the flood however it was
soon learned that the flood could not
only infect biological life forms but
also induce what is known as a logic
plague infecting a.i to do their bidding
kind of like how captain kirk logiced
those sex spots to death in that one
episode okay i'm gonna stop with the
star trek parallels i promise
after a conversation with the primordial
who was under the influence of the grave
mind mendicant bias eventually turned on
the forerunners spinning up the halo
array timetable at the very last minute
the forerunners with the help of a human
named chakas who had been placed into
the body of a halo monitor named 343
guilty spark activated the halo arrays
killing all life in the galaxy and the
flood except for the samples the
foreigners kept in storage because if
you're trying to wipe out all
lovecraftian space zombies of course
you're going to keep some as samples to
escape millions of years later that's
that's just science
eventually the ark the forerunner
installation used to make halo arrays
began reseeding aliens across the
universe with portal technology
including sending ancient humans back to
earth also i'm gonna pause right here
because it wasn't until i wrote this
script that i realized uh the flood the
ark reseeding the universe this story is
so overtly biblical that i'm surprised
master chief isn't named noah anyways
skipping ahead a few hundred thousand
years where apparently nothing important
happened the san shiyun have a return to
their original spacefaring glory now
they began seeking out foreign
technology which having forgotten their
ancient past where the foreigners you
know genocided them for a weapons test
they view as holy this eventually put
them into conflict with the warrior race
the sangheili with whom they eventually
signed an alliance creating the covenant
this alliance began to include other
races with the shanxion at its head as
prophets who misinterpreted the
activating of the halo rings as the
great journey a sacred ascendance dudes
those things wiped out your ancient
hedonistic sex planet so
actually no wait that that does sound as
puritanical as most religions no kink
shaming saint saiyun but meanwhile
humanity had also begun to spread out to
the stars founding colonies all over our
little corner of the galaxy and in the
early 26th century civil unrest had
begun to ferment with the outer colony
worlds believing that they had been
taken advantage of for their resources
leading to a civil war between
humanity's military the unsc and
insurrectionists so in order to kill
more people good unsc scientist dr
catherine halsey decided to kidnap
children make clones that eventually
died so their parents wouldn't worry
about them then raised them to be
soldiers and inject them with drugs that
killed half of them and turned the other
half into super soldiers creating the
spartans cause [ __ ] ethics am i right
one spartan though john aka the master
chief stood out from amongst the rest
and quickly became one of the unsc's
most decorated heroes finally though the
covenant encountered humanity and seeing
them as non-believers defiling the
forerunner technology on their colony
worlds they began a war to wipe us all
out and this brings us finally to the
first damn game in the series halo wars
dear god this lore is
so [ __ ] dense
the covenant began destroying humanity's
outer colonies decimating the
insurrectionist as the unsc desperately
fought a losing battle while hiding the
location of earth from the alien
scientologists on the colony world of
harvest the covenant finds a forerunner
artifact that details the location of
other foreigner technology the human
ship the spirit of fire under commander
james carter follows the covenant to the
planet arcadia once there lead
researcher dr ellen anders is kidnapped
by the covenant's arbiter a holy warrior
title bestowed upon those who have been
outcast and can only regain their honor
and death anders is forced to help the
arbiter find a forerunner fleet hidden
on a lost shield world entrance harbor
bridge entrant
harbin bieber entran
her
hoover you know what screw it you can
you can just read it this is how it's
about i can't say it and it's here that
we learned that only humans can activate
4runner technology hence why the arbiter
kidnapped anders and more on that later
anders eventually escapes the arbiter
but not before she learns of the flood
which managed to survive because someone
decided to keep samples of the luck
crafty and space zombies i'm not naming
names but someone did it the spirit of
fire eventually used its slip space
drive to destroy the forerunner fleet as
well as the flood but now unable to jump
to ftl speeds the spirit drifts through
space with the crew placed into nap nap
pods aka cryosleep you've got us all out
of there alive
get some rest
not all of us not all of us
meanwhile despite spartan twos like
master chief helping keep the covenant
at bay the war is going badly with
covenant forces continually glassing
worlds as they move closer to earth so
the unsc creates the spartan threes
basically baby discount spartans but
this time child kidnapping free so
that's cool a group of spartan 3's
called noble team is sent to the planet
of reach to put down some
insurrectionists but surprise it turns
out the covenant have begun invading
reach one of humanity's biggest colonies
and one very close to earth noble team
works to try to push back the invasion
but slowly realize they are fighting a
losing battle in a last-ditch effort
noble team sacrifices themselves to
evacuate dr halsey who is on reach
finishing up the creation of an ai
called cortana who is delivered to the
fleeing ship the pillar of autumn and
wouldn't you know it the pillar of
autumn also houses the master chief who
had been defending reach but is also now
in his own knapnap pod because everyone
gets a nap nap pod in this universe
apparently as the pillar of autumn jumps
away the last member of noble team
fights to the bitter end as reach is
glassed
[Music]
after its jump the autumn commanded by
captain keys finds itself over
installation04 the first halo array that
humanity has ever encountered the autumn
is attacked by the covenant that are
already there forcing the crew to
evacuate to the ring's surface after
rallying the surviving crew master chief
works to learn more about the ring and
push back the covenant when captain keys
goes missing the chief searches for him
only to find more escaped flood because
someone couldn't keep their damn samples
contained it was here that the chief
eventually met the aforementioned 343
guilty spark i am the monitor of
installation04
i am 343 guilty spark who brings him to
the index the key that activates the
ring which spark tells chief will kill
all the flood and covenant however when
right about to activate the ring cortana
reveals the truth that the halo array
will kill everyone not just the covenant
and the flood a construct in the core
that is absolutely unacceptable
sawed off what importance
i shall hurt you at once you sure that's
a good idea
so instead the chief books it out of
there chief and cortana instead choose
to destroy the ring using the crashed
pillar of autumn's reactor they obtain
the ship's command codes from the
flood-infected keys who is about to be
turned into a new gravemind and chief of
cortana blow up installation 0-4 and
after a job well done chief relaxes by
taking his helmet off just off camera no
i think we're just getting started
[Music]
back on earth master chief is chewbacca
with everyone getting medals except for
him when the covenant suddenly arrives
totally by accident ah crap guys this
isn't our exit chief working with
sergeant johnson and captain keys
daughter miranda keys pushes back the
covenant ship commanded by the prophet
of regret the chief is gonna jump in
this tank roll across the bridge and
blow up any inhuman son of a [ __ ] dumb
enough to get between him and the
prophet of regret pull yourself together
because you're going with it the ship
jumps away while still in earth orbit
with chief and company in tow and the
process ends up destroying half of the
city of new mambasa however regrets ship
takes chief and the crew to a new halo
array installation zero five which
regret plans to activate the prophet of
regret is planning to activate halo are
you sure
i shall light this polling ring release
its cleansing flame and burn a path into
the divine beyond pretty much so she
punches the chump to death
then dives deep into the array when the
covenant city ship high charity arrives
and starts glass and everything because
why not just glass everything at this
point that's that's basically the
covenant's mo now
okay quick interlude here because this
game technically takes place in the
middle of halo 2 so like the kool-aid
man i'm just gonna shove this one in
here
while the master chief is punching alien
slugs to death a team of elite odsts
commanded by nathan fillion i mean buck
an intelligence officer dare and buck
call me captain
are scattered around the city but slowly
reunite eventually rescuing a covenant
hergnock named virgil who defects
revealing the covenant's intention to
dig up a forerunner artifact buried deep
under africa you're gonna tell me
exactly what they're looking for
and then you're gonna help me stop him
[Music]
as all of this is going on the covenant
commander that failed to stop chief from
restoring installation 04 is given the
title of arbiter and sent to destroy
some heretics of the covenant
what would you have your arbiter do
army confronts the heretics who defected
from the covenant after finding the
surviving 343 guilty spark who revealed
the truth of the halo rings and the
falsehoods spread by the prophets ask
the oracle about halo
how they would sacrifice us all for
nothing
more questions splendid however the
brute tartarus captures guilty spark and
kills the heretics and back on high
charity the remaining prophets angered
by regret's death remove the sangheili
as the protectors replacing them with
the brutes the arbiter is then sent to
find the activation index for
installation zero five but is eventually
betrayed by tartarus and left for dead
fool
they ordered me to do it
[Music]
both chief and arbiter are eventually
saved by a newly created grave mind deep
in the bowels of installation zero five
who turns the arbiter against the
prophet and teams up with the two in
order to stop the ring from activating
the arbiter working with miranda and
johnson kills tartarus just in time to
stop the halo from firing but guilty
spark reveals that this has placed all
the other rings on standby ready to be
activated all at once remotely from the
ark meanwhile the master chief heads to
high charity to kill the prophet truth
but fails when he escapes to earth
forcing chief to leave cortana in the
clutches of the gravemind as he gives
chase to finish this fight in three
years because that's how long we had to
wait for halo 3 after this goddamn
cliffhanger
two weeks later the chief finally
arrives on earth team chief then finds
that the artifact buried in africa was
the giant transporter used to bring
early humans to earth from the ark which
the prophet of truth intends to use to
jump back to the ark to activate all the
rings killing everyone and beginning his
quote great journey your world will burn
until its surface is but glass
and not even your demon
will live to creep blackened from its
whole tomorrow reflection of our passage
the culmination of our journey
for your destruction
is the will of the gods
and
i
am their instrument
cocky bastard just loves to run his
mouth after a flood-infested ship lands
on earth team chief follows truth to the
ark with the flood just behind them
truth kills miranda keys and forces
johnson to activate the halo rings but
the arbiter working with the flood and
chief kills truth i
am
truth
the voice of the covenant
castle
you must be silenced
it's then that the grave mind turns on
team chief because come on you're really
gonna trust this thing i mean sexy
tentacles and all but
come on come on he could have only been
more evil if he had a british accent
but turns out the ark has recreated the
ring that master chief destroyed all
those years ago so chief decides to
activate it to kill the remaining flood
and the gravemind on the ark in order to
do this chief rescues cortana from the
gravemind who had been slowly working to
infect her with a logic plague and more
on that in just a little bit and the two
activate the new ring along with the
arbiter however upon learning this would
destroy the new ring guilty spark turns
traitor killing sergeant johnson because
guilty spark is a chump like that but
chief stops guilty spark and escapes
with the arbiter on the forward unto
dawn as the ring explodes killing the
gravemind however while the arbiter
eventually made it back to earth chief
and cortana's half of the ship is left
drifting in space when the portal closes
so back into the nap nap pod for chief
wake me
when you need me
afterwards the human and covenant come
to an uneasy peace with covenant
splinter groups causing chaos around
human space and insurrectionists once
again complaining about an unequal
distribution of wealth or whatever those
dang socialists
so in order to combat all these new
threats the unsc creates spartan fours
recruiting the former odst buck as well
as two new folks named sarah palmer and
john locke during this time dr halsey
after discovering a shield world on onyx
is interrogated for her crimes against
you know children which everyone
conveniently looked the other way on
until after the war i supplied the tools
to maintain that efficiency
do you believe the master chief
succeeded because he was at his core
broken
eventually though she's released under
supervision oh also during this time in
one of the novels we actually learned
the arbiter allows shangheely women to
join the covenant military because you
know he's progressive like that
years later cortana wakes up the chief
when ford unto dawn is boarded by a
covenant splinter group led by jewel
madame who still believed in the godhood
of the forerunners escaping chief
crashes on the shield world of requiem
here cortana reveals that due to her age
as well as her interactions with the
grave mind she now has rampancy which is
a condition where ais eventually think
themselves to death i was put into
service eight years ago
eight years
ai's deteriorate after seven chief
before they can do much about it though
chief discovers the human ship the
infinity has also come to requiem
following a mysterious signal chief
follows the signal and accidentally
awakens the didact yup that dude time
was your ally
human
but now it has abandoned you
turns out he's still a little tiny that
was a little bit upset at humans for the
human foreign war and plans to make all
of humanity into his ai prometheans
escaping the chief eventually finds a
remnant ai of the librarian who turns
out wanted humanity to take up the
mantle again hence why only humans can
activate forerunner technology the
librarian then makes the chief immune to
composition and also tells him that the
died act must be stopped because he's
remember british accent that's all you
need that's all you need to be evil
apparently chief and cortana return to
the infinity captain by del rio who is
kind of a giant jerk and tries to
deactivate cortana when she sews signs
of rampancy however the diet act escapes
requiem and captures the composer and
heads towards earth to assimilate
humanity in an action sequence that
looks like it was copied right out of
star trek 2009 i know i'm sorry i said i
would stop with the star trek
comparisons but come on these these two
scenes look almost exactly the same
chief defeats the dydack by plugging
cortana into a ship and eventually blows
it up for katana uses the last of the
ship's power to save the chief sending
him back to earth and supposedly
sacrificing herself though she does get
to feel up the chief for a second before
she dies so
not a bad way to go
i've waited so long to do that
back on earth the presumably now sad
chief retakes command of his spartan
blue team also in an after credit
sequence we finally get to see him
briefly without his helmet and turns out
he's just a boring dude who sadly needs
a suntan i don't know what i was
expecting
okay so this is just the dlc that we all
only played for the beautiful cutscenes
let's just admit it but right after halo
4 the infinity now commanded by
commander laysky works with dr halsey
and a team of spartan 4's captained by
sarah palmer to stop the remaining
covenant splinter groups on requiem yet
dr halsey eventually defects to jule
madame in order to learn more about the
forerunner artifacts
also in the novels around the same time
343 guilty spark was discovered having
survived the destruction of the ark and
is eventually downloaded into a robotic
carapace and with the help of the
scavenger crew of the ace of spades and
its captain ryan forge finds the last ai
imprint of the librarian who tells
guilty spark that the real great journey
is the friends that we didn't murder
along the way sadly doesn't help
sergeant johnson but what are you gonna
do
several years later dr halsey eventually
reaches out to the unsc with information
about recent attacks on the outer
colonies by mysterious foreign
technology and those outer colonies
really don't get any luck do they fire
team osiris a spartan 4 team composed of
buck and lock retrieve her and defeat
jumadama whose forerunner warriors had
inexplicably turned on him meanwhile the
chief has a vision of cortana who says
meridian is next meridian being another
outer colony world ripe for a forerunner
attack the chief and blue team go rogue
to find cortana and fire team osiris is
sent to bring them back eventually lock
catches up with the chief and they
battle but because locke is a discount
protagonist he's quickly bested
while lock rethinks his life choices
chief transports away to the planet of
genesis hey look another biblical
reference there he finds cortana who
states that her rampancy has been cured
by foreign technology and she is now in
control over the domain a vast wealth of
foreign knowledge as well as guardians
giant forum of constructs made to police
the galaxy the same things that have
been attacking the outer colonies osiris
meanwhile teams up with the arbiter to
ride a guardian to genesis where locke
reveals to chief that cortana wants to
take control of the galaxy because
evil
i'm offering people a chance to be more
than they are naturally
like dr halsey did for me
no
that monster forced you this is a gift
listen to yourself
turns out cortana believes that
artificial intelligences should be the
ones to take up the mantle with her
using the guardians to police the
quote-unquote lesser biological races
dang everyone in these games just needs
to feel superior to one another don't
they cortana leaves blue team and osiris
behind and in a scene that eerily echoes
the gravemind controlling mendicant bias
all those millions of years before all
ai in the galaxy save for the ai roland
of the infinity because plot don't worry
about it turn on their human oppressors
and join cortana the mantle of
responsibility for the galaxy shelters
all but only the created are its masters
after this chief teams up with osiris
and they meet up with dr halsey sarah
palmer and the crew of the infinity in
order to find a weapon aptly named the
weapon in order to bring down cortana
one that's based on an old technology
that halsey created back on the planet
of reach
[Music]
one year later after spending several
decades just floating around in space
having a good nap nap the crew of the
spirit of fire awakens to find that they
floated all the way to the ark which is
now controlled by the banished another
covenant splinter group under the
command of the brutal brute and wannabe
wwe fighter atriox
the spirit of fire crew begin fighting
atrox when they find out that the ark
has created a new halo to replace the
one that was destroyed by master chief
again since the ring would be
transported back towards human territory
near reach the spirit of fire crew hopes
to try to use it to get back home
however before the spirit of fight crew
can evacuate to the ring the ring jumps
into slip space with only dr anders
aboard it leaving the crew of the spirit
of fire behind as the two groups
continue to fight the banished discover
a new grave mind is growing under the
ark while atriax eventually destroys the
young lovecraftian horror in its giant
crib its existence hints that the flood
still haven't been fully defeated and
may still have some terrifying influence
on cortana through the logic play get
used on her all those years earlier
speaking of which though as the new halo
races towards human territory it
suddenly drops out of subspace curious
why dr anders works her way to the
surface of the ring only to find one of
cortana's guardians staring down at her
oh good job
and that finally thank god brings us to
halo infinite we don't know if the ring
that dr anders is on is the same ring
that will eventually appear in the
game's campaign nor how cortana's
guardians 343 guilty sparks refound
humanity atriox is banished or even the
potential for a new gravemind will all
play into the story if at all but if
this halo timeline has taught us
anything
it's the importance of a good nap nap
and that's what i'm gonna do because
i need y'all this
this was a long timeline but before i do
that don't forget to subscribe to this
channel for more coverage of halo
infinite as it comes out and also let us
know down in the comments below what
your favorite halo game is but with all
that said it's time for me to go into
cryosleep
[Music]
you